Chéré a 56 ans de métier on pourrait
donc croire que c'est grâce à
l'expérience que son traain est plus
hésitant mais en fait il ne l'a jamais
été le dessinateur est autodidacte il
s'est même fait exclure de l'unique
cours de dessin auquel il s'est rendu à
14 ans car il ne rentrait pas vraiment
dans le moule ce grand lecteur de Tarzan
rentre au journal radar à 22 ans puis
chez vaillant qui deviendra plus tard
Pif Gadget il dessine d'abord les
aventures de l'aviateur Bob mard dont il
a repris le dessin puis décide de créer
son propre personnage je pensais en
faire un Gaulois je l'avais habillé avec
une chaîne avec des des pot de bête et
puis des des des jambères et tout et
puis quand je l'ai proposé à la
rédaction du journal on m'a dit bah
tiens justement on a un scénariste Roger
Lecureux que je connaissais bien qui a
qui voulait faire lui un personnage de
d'homme préhistorique donc monongolois
est devenu un homme préhistorique c'est
pour ça qu'il est blond il illustre le
premier album de Ran durant l'été 68 il
est dans le sud de la France avec sa
famille dans une caravane et travaille
de nuit parution en mars 69 le succès
est immédiat au total 4000 pages
illustrées c'est l'œuvre d'une vie avec
une méthodologie toujours rigoureuse
mais une vraie facilité je reçois le
scénario et je le lis je lis toute toute
l'histoire et après ça je je pars
directement avec les des petits dessins
comme e ça les les mises en page non je
vais jamais de croquti je je fais après
ça je je pars directement sur la planche
sur sur une planche comme ça par
exemple avec des sa pâte du dynamisme du
suspense et des visages extrêmement
expressifs un dessin inspiré des Code du
cinéma et juste retour des choses un
film est en projet ran devrait
s'accaparer les ses obscur en 2015 et
André Cheret supervise le projet mais
d'ici là pas le temps de chômer un
nouvel album est prévu pour l'an
prochain